et
de quoi on parle aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
on parle de cette montre est cette monde
c'est quoi et bien c'est la huawei watch
j'étais honneur runner pour la course la
course on est sur une piste pas vous
avez compris je pense qu'elle a ressenti
les grosses ficelles alors je vous est
ce que ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
on va relater ce qu on va regarder
ensemble ce qu'on peut faire avec cette
huawei watch j'étais runner et je vous
le dis directement ne vous arrêtez pas
au nom de l'amour ce n'est pas une honte
faite que pour les runner que pour ceux
qui courent si vous faites du lancer de
javelot du lancer de poids de la
natation du vélo à l'intérieur à
l'extérieur de la marche nordique du ski
ce que vous voulez vous pouvez le faire
avec cette montre ça c'est vachement
cool et elle est vraiment intéressante
parce que les liens très gros travail
technologique fait part aux élus au
niveau du capteur de rythme cardiaque
ils ont amélioré pareil au niveau du gps
et un écran qui est incroyable et a
surtout une très grosse autonomie on va
jusqu'à 15 jours alors si vous voulez
courir pendant 15 jours vous pourrez
vous aurez la montre avec vous ça c'est
sûr que les âges normal son usage
intensif voudrait est à peu près à sept
huit jours donc on a un truc qui
vachement atteindre non qu'est ce qu'on
fait et bien on va courir je vais quoi
vous vous allez être assis dans votre
canapé je sais pas où est ce que vous
regardez cette vidéo d'ailleurs dit le
maintenant en commentaire petit passage
en verre de la vidéo chez moi dans le
métro bref peu importe mais peut-être
paiements courants ça serait bien le
terme de solidarité moi je veux courir
spoiler alert je suis pas sportif donc
je planchais donc c'est marrant bon
voilà c'est pas si c'est marrant mais je
mangeais
juste avant de partir sous la monte
rapidement pour vous voyez un peu à quoi
il ressemble l'écran est vraiment super
bien très beau lumineuse c'est de la
molette bref c'est donc là ils ont deux
finitions soit hongrie comme vous l'avez
la soie en noir le truc qui est
vachement bien exception c'est qu'elle
est très légère elle fait tranquille
cinq grammy elle est vachement
confortable par contre attention ici il
ya une seule taille c'est du 46 mm là où
à bien bosser huawei ce qu'ils nous ont
fait tout un boîtier en fibres de
polymères durable alors bon au delà du
côté un peu technique ça va venir
apporter en légèreté vous avez en plus
des finitions céramique et une couronne
qui en alliage de titane votre bracelet
bien évidemment c'est complètement du
silicone pour venir courir cette âme ce
cas mieux et puis que dire cet écran
c'est crans et de la molette les ducs à
166 par 466 hd 1,43 pouces et surtout il
est extrêmement lumineuse donc en
extérieur vous verrez vraiment bien ce
qui est affiché et ça c'est chouette et
en plus rassurez vous il est protégé
avec un verre corning gorilla glass 3 ce
qui est très bien vu de la part du web
ce sont les antennes au niveau du gps le
positionnement et changez vous avez des
antennes flottante ce qui fait qu'elles
sont pas à l'intérieur du corps de la
montre mais bien dans toute la partie
est du polymère ce qui fait le signal va
pas être bloquée par des partis en métal
vous avez un gnss bibande à cinq
systèmes cinq systèmes ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous avez les
principaux systèmes de navigation par
satellite gps glonass galileo et
compagnie donc ça permettra d'avoir un
positionnement plus rapide plus précis
ça lorsque vous allez courir et vous
avez besoin de voir votre itinéraire
voir par vous êtes passés là c'est
vachement bien il ya un autre truc est
bien vu c'est au niveau de votre capteur
de fréquence cardiaque son doublé ici le
nombre de capteurs et sais pas si vous
entendez qu'on vous avez une petite
inclinaison ici qui permet une meilleure
mesure pour être mieux plaqué à votre
peau vous avez deux boutons ici
principal qui est votre menu au nous
avoir tous vos menus alors vous avez
évidemment tous ces mondes connectés et
non pour passer des appels d'écouter de
la musique dans toutes les fonctions du
monde connecté vous les aurez
l'entraînement à l'entraînement me
retrouver ici parce que vous avez un
petit bouton dessous ce sport là pour
vous appuyer et ça vous emmène
directement dans votre entraînement
alors regardez c'est assez cool parce
que vous avez effectivement vos cours et
un programme d'entraînement le temps de
récupération ben moi j'ai rien fait pour
l'instant que ces progrès de récupérer
mais ça vous marque créée après parce
qu'en fait elle va venir connaître vos
habitudes et elle vous proposera aussi
un temps de récupération en fonction de
votre programme qui vous est plein de
choses du cros extérieure qu intérieure
de la majorité du cyclisme du vélo de la
natation soit l'accord du ski du
snowboard bref c'est vraiment une langue
qui est fait pour tout le monde pour
tous les sportifs ou à des paramètres
d'entraînement enfin il ya vachement de
choses et c'est super cool et une fois
de plus sa navigation est extrêmement
efficace donc la voie je reviens ici sur
mon bouton home je vais retrouver mon
histoire d'entraînement mon statut mon
rythme cardiaque ma spo2 également
sanitas est tout de suite parti sur le
bien-être qu'on peut venir paramétrer
avec son application aux oies santé
directement depuis son smartphone de
huawei c'est aussi une qui axe et pas
que port mais aussi santé avec le
monitoring du sommeil le stress bien
évidemment connaître votre fréquence
cardiaque des exercices respiratoires
puis tout ce qui est jeté dans un peu
standard les contacts les appelle la
musique vous pouvez venir connecter si
vos petits freebug et puis écouter de la
musique en faisant du sport pourquoi pas
déclencher votre appareil photo à
distance le baromètre on connaît la
pression on a combien la voyez on est à
1 988 hectopascals hockey vous avez
aussi votre boussole d'envoyer un plat
le nord c'est par là les notifications
la météo bref si le monde connecté donc
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec une loupe
connectés pétales maps pour votre
quartier venir vous repérer vos
paramètres et je trouve très complet
très sympa prévenir en plus elle essaie
l'écran allumé le temps dont vous avez
besoin le drainage et puis je crois
qu'on a fait à peu près le tour
unification pour l'instant il y en a pas
vous avez votre petit météo enfin bref
voyez on axait pas mal de choses donc
personnellement je trouve ça plutôt cool
et nous on va se choisir ici à sers toi
comme ce porte avions à choisir un petit
look plutôt simple course en extérieur
c'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
alors localisation en cours au travers
du gps donc là je le laisse bosser le
gps etc allez je suis déjà à 105 autant
dire qu'on est un petit peu speed je
suis là j'ai glissé l'un monte vers la
droite pour moi le parcours donc ça
c'est la musique là j'ai mon trajet
trajet de retour donc ça rassure mon gps
donc on va voir exactement où est ce que
j'en suis donc la meito tout ça on s'en
fout un peu et puis voyez donc là je
suis tout au début qu'on va y aller on
en phase d'échauffement et puis on va
monter progressivement donc on y va et
puis en gras ça on en a pour un petit
quart d'heure de course ça va partir
ouais t'es show a surpris les joueurs
plaît allez c'est parti
[Rires]
chez intel core i je suis allée
robichaud et extrêmes comme ça je vois
où j'en suis je mon rythme j'ai
quasiment 60 bon je m'arrête pas parce
que maintenant c'est de mourir ce
n'est pas possible mais c'était moi
bonne chance
tout est écrit en français mais elle me
parle anglais aux gens vont regarder une
finale du super bowl voilà c'est ce truc
genre découlent
ouais y'a pas tous les stades mais aussi
la nature on peut courir dehors en
pleine nature
[Musique]
dans cet accent américain mais c'est
vrai que tout cas soit en français c'est
le seul truc huawei il faut que j'ai une
voix françaises pourtant tout était
d'écrire france ici donc c'est gérer un
vent une wave écrit en français bongo
jackpot mais déjà là c'est vachement
cool alors regardez je vous montre on
garde le rythme je suis de karim a foulé
les jets plusieurs écrans sur lesquels
j'ai toutes mes infos donc lâché en
cours servir après plus je monte là j'ai
carrément extrêmes on va se faire mais
mon petit lapin quoi là c'est vraiment
que de la course extérieur j'ai des
intervalles je vois mon temps
d'intervalle bref peut servir à chaumont
de choses voyez ça fait un petit quart
d'heure que nos dix minutes que je cours
sur un quart d'heure ça c'est mon
programme qui dure un quart d'heure en
fait la distance parcourue on a dû
changer de poste c'est pour ça que j'en
ai fait un petit peu moins bon mais vous
êtes toutes vos infos différents écrans
donc on a vraiment ce qu'on veut ça
c'est cool par ses chronos équivalent
bien vraiment axé sur le rythme
cardiaque comme ça on voit où on en est
je montre à 160,1 final je vais mourir
et la voyez un truc vachement cool
j'adore les écrans c'est vraiment bien
et là dessus je peux reconnaître que
huawei a vraiment fait le taff et ça
c'est cool stress à l'entraînement
jusque là tout va bien puis voyons tous
ont fait le tour pourquoi est ce une
espèce de boucle et elle et je trouve ça
tout ça cool parce que en fonction de ce
dont vous avez besoin vous le voyez
voyez évoqué ce qu'on peut faire donc on
peut faire de la course à pied à
l'intérieur de l'extérieur et tout plein
d'autres choses il devrait faire un
autre truc qu'on va arrêter
regardez là j'ai même mon trajet trajet
retour alors landes affiche petit bouc
tu vous êtes revenu au point de départ
parce qu'on a marché on a fait du
surplace et toi junk un entraînement
est menée donc si vous partez dans les
bois autour d'un stade c'est facile vous
retrouver rapidement le chemin mais là
dans les bois vous partez piémont 8 mars
parce que je suis claque ça vous ramène
et c'est vachement cool cette idée
d'avoir effectivement une position très
précise au niveau du gps parce qu'on
sait où on est on sait où on va alors
regardez en faire autre chose alors
qu'on sent extérieur ok donc la voyez
j'ai mes petites infos je vois ce que
j'ai fait ce que j'ai brûlé en calories
j'ai pas de cours pas vite je suis
vraiment en mode reprise donc je me fais
honte moi même mais c'est pas grave
alors regardez on retourne ici on peut
faire quoi de la marche de cyclistes du
vélo on va faire un peu de muscu tu vois
voilà donc là on va faire un peu de
muscu on va d'abord s'échauffent un peu
les bras les gens sont déjà créés
s'échauffent un peu les bras puis on va
faire quelques petites pompeux dans tous
les sens
à l'armée moi j'ai jamais tes larmes et
ça je peux même le faire on entendait
plutôt faux mais la faute est un peu
ridicule vraiment l'otan
[Musique]
avec un petit peu dit bien resta pas
fort en 1944 je vois ma petite georges
assez cool un sentiment devant un petit
jeu là mais là je peux arrêter le 100 m
la pause master en poche je peux arrêter
tac et la semaine mesurer le rythme
cardiaque de récupération après un
entraînement et bah ouais t'es là comme
ça je mesure un peu pendant récup je
pense qu'il en est et ça c'est bien côté
capteur on a un accéléromètre un
gyroscope un capteur géomagnétique et
oui pour la boussole le fameux capteur
optique de fréquence cardiaque dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure un capteur
de pression d'air pour connaître
l'attitude et y'a un truc qui va si on
accepte non c'est vous la recharger en
induction vous avez un petit port vous
venez de poser dessus vous le charger
directement sur un ordinateur ou sur une
prise sans problème sans sachant qu'ici
vous n'avez pas le look des charges vous
avez bien le cordon avec la partie qui
va être aimanté mais pas le blog de
charge mais après vous prenez le bloc de
charge de retour en forme de gros et ça
fera la faire si vous avez un smartphone
avec de la recherche inversée et que
vous manquez l'autonomie de vous à moi
si vous ne manquez d'autonomie là dessus
ça serait surprenant 14 jours 14 jours
sept jours en utilisation intensive
pendant un an il en faut et bien vous
prenez votre smartphone vous activer la
recharge inversée et vous la posez
dessus et ça va la recharger comme par
magie enfin presque c'est la technologie
cette montre allait forcément compatible
avec tous les smartphones de huawei et
avec harmonie os donc ça c'est cool et
c'est vachement bien mais si vous avez
un smartphone sous android ou ios elle
sera également compatible donc ça c'est
aussi la bonne nouvelle après avait
quelques fonctions au moins vous allez
avoir 90 % expérience de votre monde qui
va fonctionner avec et un petit chouya
chouïa que vous n'aurez pas qu'il va
être vraiment réservé à votre smartphone
huawei donc si vous voulez maximiser
l'expérience au smartphone huawei si
vous avez un smartphone android ou ios
et qu'elle vous fait de l'oeil vous
pouvez quand même l'acheter et ça c'est
la bonne nouvelle est d'ailleurs si vous
voulez acheter elle est dispo oui elle
est dispo au tarif de 299.99 alors on
pourrait dire effectivement c'est un
petit budget puisque nous assurer que vu
le taf qui a été fait ici au niveau de
l'écran la qualité l'écran est vraiment
vraiment belle on voit très bien en
pleine lumière donc là on n'a pas un
grand soleil dingue vous avez remarqué
c'est quand même relativement rythme et
on voit très bien et en plus du fait
d'avoir un écran lumineux on a une halte
est vraiment
excellent boitier merci ça va être
portée à l'écran
[Rires]
une super qualité il est effectivement
très lumineux on est sûr de l'amoled on
a de très très belles couleurs et c'est
vrai qu'il ya un très beau tarkett effet
dessus l'innovation qu'on a aussi au
niveau du gps de pas la mettre dans le
corps mais de la mettre sur les côtés au
niveau du polymère pour mieux capter
c'est vachement malin ça fonctionne ce
capteur de fréquence cardiaque est
complètement optimise et avec deux fois
plus de capteurs à l'intérieur c'est
vraiment bien parce que c'est très
précis et puis toute l'expérience
logiciel qui est ici et qui est
vachement intuitive qui fonctionne
vraiment bien quel que soit votre sport
que vous soyez cyclistes que vous soyez
un nageur que vous soyez coureurs que
vous soyez leveurs de deux d'alter
haltérophiles voilà bref il y en a pour
tout le monde et ça c'est bien
connu pour des troubles n'avaient pas
trop fâché ça mais c'est trois fois si
vous avez ou être aussi 5.0 plus qui
vous permettra un vrai suivi de votre
rythme cardiaque et en plus ce qui est
cool c'est ça supprime et parasites
alors déjà que c'est précis et en plus
c'est les petits parasites salem en
laisse comme ça vous savez est
réellement vous en êtes et vous avez
vraiment de la visibilité je sais pas si
l'attraction époque je pense que sa
femme arrête ou moi on dirait un panda
panda
des mesures extrêmement précises au
niveau de la fréquence cardiaque et de
son lit quand on fait du sport ou quand
on fait le panda puis on a ici en plus
huawei trou sport qui est un programme
scientifique du course à pied vous avez
retrouvé votre indice d'aptitude de
course à pied vous allez avoir une note
une quantification précise et efficace
qui va être basé sur plein de donner
votre historique de fréquence cardiaque
bah oui parce que plus vous allez en
faire et plus votre montre va vous
connaître et plus huawei santé va vous
connaître on va voir votre rythme
cardiaque on va connaître la distance
que vous parcourez mais également la
fréquence de votre course puis vous
fixer les objectifs et vous verrez si
vous les avez atteint et où est-ce que
vous en êtes alors soit vous les avait
dépassées soit vous les avez pas
dépasser et votre montre à venir adapter
votre programme de façon complètement
intelligente pour vraiment venir coller
ce que vous êtes en capacité de faire
donc soit adapté un peu à la baisse sont
adaptés à la hausse vous avez un vrai
plan d'entraînement qui vous êtes
totalement personnalisée et en plus dans
votre application ou angoissante et vous
allez rentrer déjà ou est-ce que vous en
êtes et vous votre corps votre taille
votre poids le nombre de pas que vous
voulez faire bref manière totalement
personnaliser l'expérience dire voilà je
suis là aujourd'hui moi par exemple je
vous le dis je suis une grosse bouse il
faut que je fasse du sport et bien je
décide de faire plus de pages essayé de
courir davantage décidé de courir sans
rien deux ou trois fois par semaine
d'aller nager à la piscine ou de faire
du vélo et bien là vous allez avoir un
vrai suivi ça va être monitorer vous
verrez dans le temps où est-ce que vous
en êtes et une fois de plus à votre
intelligence à s'adapter dans sauf que
l'idée vraiment bonne et vous voyez
également votre charge d'entraînement
hebdomadaire c'est à dire le temps de
récupération après un effort intensif
mais également quel volume
d'entraînement vous convient afin
d'éviter les blessures l'idée c'est pas
de partir comme un dingue et puis de ce
degré du sport de cette fait mal et puis
de jamais recommencer l'idée c'est de
pérenniser sa et de pouvoir aller loin
dans le temps connaissait l'histoire qui
veut aller loin ménage sa monture mais
voilà votre monture c'est vous aussi
vous voulez aller loin on y va à la cool
et en plus de ça vous suggestion
l'entraînement par rapport à vos données
par rapport à votre temps de fatigue par
rapport à votre récupération à
l'intensité de l'effort aérobie mais
également anaérobie bref votre montre
elle fait office de coach personnalisé
qui va vous aider à atteindre vos
objectifs sans vous faire mal pour vous
puissiez progresser prend du plaisir et
à la fin vous sentir bien dans votre
corps et je crois que ça quand même ses
plus importants avec un entraînement qui
est divisé en quatre parties départ mise
à niveau consolidation et réductions sa
part a probablement aux plus sportifs
d'entre eux ils vous retrouvez tout
votre apport d'entraînement dans votre
application web huawei santé pour les
français dans votre smartphone de huawei
bien évidemment donc ça en fait c'est la
vue d'ensemble de ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui c'est la première course 1
kilomètre 75 on a cru qu enfin j'ai
couru passer tous coup tout seul en fait
j'ai couru quinze minutes et j'ai couru
huit kilomètres heure ce qui est pas
ridicule parce que globalement moi je
suis plein quoi donc vous voyez on voit
bien la position de départ la position
où je me suis arrêté là je me suis
arrêté un moment il ya un petit tapis si
la saison s'était parlé la lure moyenne
la durée l'énergie que j'ai brûlé ça
s'adresse concept le point de retours
enregistrés dans mes parcours dont
castrés paco je peux le partager ok donc
là je dis dans mes parcours je vais
avoir mon allure j'ai le segment en
graphiques en fait il va chez moi parce
que j'ai un vrai reporting tu voies
extrêmes cinq minutes j'étais extrêmes
pendant cinq minutes incroyable
anaérobie six minutes aérobie une minute
brûlage de graisse moins d'une minute
sur les bosses et un peu cette partie je
pense monsieur re et puis l'échauffement
une petite minute tranquille détail et
là j'ai tout en fait c'est vrai que je
veux dire monitorer voir ce qu'il en est
et m'améliorer l'ascension ce n'est pas
énorme mais bon on était un petit peu
sur du plat stress d'entraînement
anaérobie minimes et la vo2 max et ben
plutôt pas mal j'ai l'impression donc je
sais bien que c'est après on a les
deuxièmes ensuite qu'on a fait tout à
l'heure donc là c'est parti sur un petit
chemin on a fait un peu des
allers-retours pas couru beaucoup mais
ça dure et 11 minutes le segment et bien
voyez en a ça on va retrouver notre
petit graphique ici avec les différentes
séquences la lure franchement il ya
plein de choses à aller chercher un
c'est super bien toutes les dates alger
ici au niveau du sport et puis la partie
autres sur la musculation vous avez vu
on a forcément un peu moins d'un faux
parce que ça n'entrait pas dans le cadre
d'un programme mais on a quand même des
infos qu'on va retrouver ici diminution
14 pour soucier de leur rythme leur
rythme cardiaque danse et de la
récupération à la fin ce que j'avais
s'activer la récupération je vois
vachement de choses que ce soit sur la
partie de récupération sur mon sport ce
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui j'avais
données complètes j'ai couru deux
kilomètres consiste peut paraître
ridicule pour tout le monde mais je peux
vous assurer que pour moi c'est loin
d'être ridicule et je pense même que
c'est un accomplissement personnel de ma
journée voilà un vrai que plus belle ma
journée est d'ailleurs des smartphones
devant vous et j'en ai beaucoup parlé
notamment le no 20 nov allez jeter un
petit coup d'oeil à ma vie aussi pas
déjà le cas alors le seul truc un peu
zarbi ici je dirais cette fonction de
guidage en temps réel comme vous avez pu
l'entendre avec pour l'instant une voix
en anglais alors j'imagine que c'est
juste une question de mise à jour
logicielle et que voir où il va vous
déployez une version en français très
bientôt pour vous et votre coach qui
vous parle allez on y va latta couru
maintenant tu marches tout récurent
perds tu repars c'est bien vas-y mon
lapin était en pleine patate alors si
vous voyez veux prendre ma voix pour
vous dire c'était mon petit lapin temps
plein patate jeu bien ça me ferait
marrer à l'e3 et mon petit lapin c'est
bon alors tu tiens le rythme a un truc
allez vas-y non c'est pas vrai là tu
fais la louche qu'est ce que tu fais est
allé on pousse on pousse en poussant
pouces et comme vous le disais c'est pas
seulement un nom pour faire du sport
c'est aussi le monde de santé que vous
avez votre suivi de fréquence cardiaque
saturation en oxygène dans le sang
également tout votre sommeil qui va être
monitorer également votre cycle
menstruel si vous êtes une dame parce
que si vous êtes un monsieur est un peu
différent vous pouvez également partager
votre itinéraire de course avec d'époque
terme atteint ce spot là ils écoulent
eux partagent également le rythme hier
matin va courir là bas c'est vachement
cool va courir c'est vachement bien
enfin il ya un côté aussi qui est social
qui est sympa tout que cette montre elle
est très sympa pour tous les sportifs
tous ceux qui veulent aller plus loin
ceux qui ont vraiment besoin d'une
montre complètement dédié au sport il ya
d'autres montrent un ce soit chez huawei
ou ailleurs qui iront très bien aussi
pour faire du sport mais celle là elle a
deux particularités qui sont vraiment
intéressantes le capteur de fréquence
cardiaque est vraiment optimisé et le
positionnement des antennes gps l'écran
qui est super qualité et surtout la très
grosse autonomie et ça c'est cool
d'avoir une très grosse autonome 14
jours à 14 jours quatorze jours à 14
jours non c'est trop cool mais
c'est quoi je pense que pour partie
hachée par de petits sportifs et les
squats au pape mais tout le temps la
petite aurait pas de quoi tu parce que
les squats et ont tenté cuisse c'est bon
pour les fessiers et croyez moi l'été
arrivant bientôt si vous faites des
squats ou à l'efb beauvois là haut on my
own et toi et si vous en souhaitez faire
du sport eh ben c'est pas grave c'est
quand même beau sur la plage et ça c'est
bon allez vous embrasser pas ce que vous
en pensez de cette jolie montre en bar
commentaire est-ce que vous êtres avec
un smartphone de wawel est ce que vous
vous êtes dans l'écosystème du web parce
que chez huawei effectivement démontré
les ordinateurs il ya des smartphones
des écrans vous en ai parlé les costa
mais vachement bien parce que les
appareils communiquent entre eux dont je
vous invite à aller voir mes autres
vidéos sur les appareils de ba ouais
merci huawei d'abord se sauver cette
vidéo faire c'est envoyer deux morts
parmi ses manières mètres en plein pêche
je croyais encore du taf mais en tout
cas c'est un permis de me rendre compte
vous assure que c'est complètement fou
et donc j'arrivais à peu près à courir
un des ces fonds un moyen orientaux ou
pas les mollets beaucoup de monde ce
matin je suis parti c'était plat et là
ça va voilà donc je suis sûr qu'il faut
aller
merci à vous les studios
[Musique]